si votas a podemos tienes que ver este vídeo
y es que hoy te voy a demostrar
con datos que son igual de casta
e igual de sinvergüenzas que el resto de partidos
pero antes de empezar
es necesario puntualizar una cosa
que no mucha gente sabe
y es que en españa
es completamente legal
que la administración adjudique contratos a dedo
si el valor de estos es inferior a €15 000
di hecho con otras palabras
que si el político de turno
quiere encargar material de oficina
con valor de €14 999 a la tienda de su primo
puede hacerlo
y qué tiene que ver esto con podemos
que todas las cuentas y contratos que firma el estado
son públicos es decir
cualquiera puede entrar a internet y consultarlos
y si por ejemplo
consultamos las cuentas del ministerio de igualdad
que recuerdo está dirigido por podemos
nos encontramos con esto
decenas y decenas de contratos adjudicados a dedo
por valores muy cercanos a esos €15 000 de límite
pues ellos obviamente para cosas superimportantes
como por ejemplo con valor de €14 950
un proyecto piloto de mejora de la funcionalidad
de la explotación
del portal estadístico de la violencia de género
que qué cojones es eso
pues qué más da si aquí hay dinero para todos ahora
pero más aparte
imaginaos esto
en cada uno de los 22 ministerios
que conforman nuestro gobierno
es un auténtico despropósito
si esta no es la definición de chiringuito
por favor que alguien me lo explique